台北國際會議中心
我們邀請到
新南股神陳偉良
存股教父古瑜
總經學霸紀委名
還有安聯投信的投資長張偉銘
安聯投信執行董事蕭惠中
一起來講AI關鍵資源
全球布局戰略
有哪一些是重量級的身隊友
是免費的喔
趕快到東森財經的官網報名吧
還是要提醒
我們來講
台北國際會議中心
我們邀請到台北國際會議中心
的官網報名吧
還是要提醒
投資一定有風險
基金投資有賺有賠
申購錢一定要享樂
公開說明書
歡迎收看
最佛心幽默的財經節目
理財達人秀
我是李兆華
好 今天台股是繼續反彈的
第二天上個禮拜五
哇賽 3800點的漲點
真的讓人家覺得很吃驚
但是上個禮拜五的夜盤
我們是稍微有修正的
今天的台股算是
整个亚洲股市里面最厉害的
今天有110档的公司是所涨停板
分散在各个热门族群
有载板有CPU有被动元件等等的
不过大家也难免余计有存
会想要问说好不容易
如果手上的股票没有卖
到今天反弹第二天了
我到底要确定的是
我如果手上还有现金
这个时候是加码点吗
如果我手上这些股票已经弹了
我是不是应该觉得先出场一趟
免得像上礼拜杀得我措手不及
可是又看到很多的外资报告
事实上对台股的科技产业还是十分的看好
以及像是上个礼拜五联发科开发说
虽然看起来跟去年获利有点年减的状态
但市场却十分买单
到了所谓的年底
有所谓的ESIC会开出来的利多消息
利多有反应
利空似乎还在背后隐隐作祟的情况
我们该如何判断
今天的来宾已经把策略拟好
希望大家经过惊涛駭浪之后
可以安心投资
来欢迎他们
第一位是我们的题材猎人汉伟哥
好汉伟哥也要讲
这个周末怎么样
川普又说美伊不打了
而市场似乎还是买单
只是今天哦
韩股日股都是有点开高走低
剩下我们独强哦
来帮大家独家检验
到底盘面上的这些利空散去了吗
还是利多会反应
我们就要按个赞
两大产业波动大的记忆体和载版
事实上内资外资各有拥护者
我们来看一下筹码跟前景的状况
第二位是我们的冠军操盘手云翔哥
看到云翔哥只想问一件事
云翔哥云翔哥你的选择权批
买好了没
这边给大家一个定心丸
买好了
上个礼拜买
哇塞就立刻礼拜五吃了一个龟灵糕
但是买好龟买好
這個是一個避險的策略喔
但反彈到這裡
雲翔哥其實有列出很明確的SOP要來教大家了
今天細光子也強談
被動元件也強談
到底該留還是該走
等一下我們看這個SOP怎麼做
另外如果基本面好的
一樣看廠物工程
EPS這麼高
再手訂單這麼多
到底雲翔哥看誰等一下來揭曉
第三位是我們的齊全王子張寧忠
忠哥
先跟大家說
外资空单来到了9万口
钟哥有没有担心呢
我们今天在雅谷独强的态势
能不能从齐全筹码看到端倪
能不能继续往下走呢
还有钟哥有发现从个股齐
我们现在其实市场有往稳定资产
跑到风险资产了
等一下来教您
KD向上黄金交叉
有重要的均线维持上扬
有哪一些这样的征兆
让你选股更方便哦
好首先有请汉伟哥
好汉伟哥我们上个礼拜惊涛骇浪
这个礼拜第一天算是续谈的第一天
不过说实话美伊要打不打
对不对
韩股的去杠杆
甚至在日币的去杠杆
到底有没有化解了一些了
利多已经开始反应了
8月的台股有没有办法乐观看待
我觉得目前来看的话
稍微可以乐观一点
不会像七月那么惨
但你看到连续两天亮缩
所以代表市場比較緊鎮來看待
所以發生到資金
其實都往一些特定途徑去跑
今天機理摘板表現都還不錯
那我們來看一下就是說
原本大家擔心在禮拜五
開始期的夜盤跌了1000點
那時候其實川普說要打一郎
好
對那你看到到禮拜天
他說我們不要打一郎
那今天有可能要展開新一輪的談判
那一郎說沒有這回事
對這真的是
我覺得太佩服了
從3月到現在8月了
它還能影響盤面那麼大
對 所以我覺得這個還是
羅生門繼續下去
但我們還是回到油價的表現
那油價你可以看到
今天是往下跌到82左右
那7月份為什麼台股跌那麼慘
就是因為油價直線拉升到100
所以我覺得當然就是川普
還是這個全市場最大的投顧
喊盤喊得動啦
所以目前來看
我覺得油價只要在8月份
不要再往上衝高
那對於整個8月份的全球資金環境來講
稍微可以降溫
因為大家還擔心9月份會不會升息啊
所以你8月份油價在高檔
9月份如果升息預期又拉高的話
可能這個讓大家痛苦的事件會再度發生
所以第一件事情是
地緣戰爭的風險看起來有點在緩和
第二件事情大家關心的是
那這個所謂的去杠杆的情況
那韓國股市當然是
7月份全球中量在去
韓國股市7月份跌的大概四成
那如果以這個外資的研究報導說
韓股從6月22號以來跌了四成
然後槓桿規模已經減到70%
從525億降到170億的美元
你想想看這件事情
如果發在我們的主動型ETF
還是政二ETF
那可能就是一個
我們可能也要上街去遊行了
所以這個當然代表說
整個韓國股市因為急跌過後
整個籌碼有開始沉澱下來
所以他們說
現在整個外資的資金
開始有回補到韓國股市
韓股一直有一些新的政策對不對
下午我們聽到最新的是
他們可能在演你
要把槓桿型兩倍
變成緊急的時候
可以只要1.1倍槓桿
哇 感覺上韓谷
還是一個動盪的情況
對 因為我們台灣
也有曾經發生過這種事情
對 因為可能就是所謂的
投信它跟所謂的
期貨之間
它可能沒有辦法做
那麼大口數
所以它倍數也曾經調整過
哦 原來我們也發生過
對 所以有時候它在追蹤
它會說 像之前的所謂
原油真額就有這樣的情況
所以我覺得這個
但調整也是這個因應市場
降低風險的一個主要手段
但目前來看我們回到台灣本身
你可以看到外資還是很愛台灣
荷蘭IMG調高今年的GDP
台灣成長率是11.1%
然後銳銀11%
台經院中經院跟主技術都10%以上
所以我們會講說
台股雖然你會覺得短向偏空
但我覺得中長線
你還是可以比較樂觀來看待
因為我們基本面真的是非常的好
所以我在這樣的情況裡面
就可以看到今天的台股
那当然大家还是会担心说
你看这个现行
实际上来看
还是比较平常空房有利嘛
只是反弹
对只是反弹
因为我们讲连续两天反弹都量缩
所以量能没有出来
代表市场的追加意愿
其实是不太够的
对那我们再看到就是说
如果以这个现在的情况
我们会看到
我觉得台股啊
要真的出现转强
还是要伴随
第一个量能要增加
然后外资要翻多
但9万多口空单要翻多
有点困难
但我們講現貨最少要開始連續的買超
那上禮拜我是大賣
所以我覺得如果我說這個禮拜
看到台幣轉生 外資現貨轉買
也許期貨空單就不用太過擔心
那再來說我們去槓桿
在7月份融資大減了2000億
所以我們其實槓桿有慢慢在降溫的跡象
那現在就等到
如果接下來有資金環境的利多的話
也許台股8月份先蹲
9月份就有機會往上跳升
但還是有很多的變數
那剛剛跟大家講說你現在觀察
我覺得8月份的上旬
是多方公席的時間期
主要原因在說
大家可以發現
下面有一些鍵號
那這個鍵號
你可以當這個紅色箭頭是月線
月線的扣底值對上去在這邊
你會發現到
未來大概7到8天是往下扣
那我們再看到季線的位置
大概在這個地方
對上去
未來7到8天往下扣
所以現在我們的
月線跟季線
已經死亡交叉了
對 所以我覺得
中空的架構慢慢在成形
好 這必須承認
對 所以現在我就市場的多頭
他如果真的想要扭轉這個
中空格局的話
什麼都要發動
就是要等到月季線在下彎的時候
你拉伸是可以事半功倍
因為未來均線你只要怎麼樣
回到季線以上撐住
那就會變成季線跟月線會轉回上彎
所以多方格局就有機會延續下去
如果在8月上旬有利多而不漲
那可能大家還是要去做一些
適度的太弱流強的動作
目前來看我覺得還可以觀察個幾天
那再來就是說有沒有這樣的態勢
我們可以看到最少我們台灣權王先表態了
對 所以我說上個禮拜五
台積電拉到漲停板
是有它的宣示意味存在的
那今天台積電為什麼量縮下來
就是剛剛講的
上禮拜大概有點太激情
所以尾盤我覺得就是有點多漲的
把它吐回去了
因為在上禮拜五
美股的ADR並沒有跌
所以我覺得現在的情況就是說
台積電今天大概是
漲多回升到月線關卡
但它季建是守稳的
所以我觉得如果在8月10号之前
台积电要公布它的期限营收
理论上应该也是创高
所以这些都反映到
就是说台积电如果在这段时间里面
它能够发挥它的稳盘工作
守在季建以上
那我觉得其实盘市
你就不用看得太过于悲观
对整个台股的大盘
或者说对于中小型股的多方轮动
会有机会
在台积电稳盘情况里面
大家就可以去想
那有没有一些股票跌升
有机会反弹的
那我们看到今天盘面上
整理上
記憶體算是一個當中算蠻整齊的族群
但是這個就是這一次南韓的正央對不對
今天其實韓國五的三星
這個海力是沒有漲了
是因為上禮拜五漲太多
反而是我們補漲所漲停
觀眾朋友到底該怎麼樣操作這個族群
才能夠低買高賣
我們先講結論
我覺得目前來看籌碼的問題
不只台灣
美國跟韓國跟日本都一樣
就是之前漲太多了
所以他們有些人說要去槓桿的情況
所以籌碼問題沒有解決之前
我覺得大家都以區間操作為主
那觀察幾個指標
第一個財報
因為禮拜8月5號
這個Sendix跟西部處就要公布他的財報
然後8月6號滑幫店
然後是這個盤後
所以大致上來講就是禮拜三禮拜四
對這兩天我覺得就是記憶體的檢視期
就是記憶體的股票怎麼看
他們公布出來財報
如果是利多股價會漲
那代表這一波可能修正完了
籌碼也變乾淨了
那如果說公布出來
財報不好股價會跌
那你就要特別小心
他們可能就後面要補給了壓力
這一點大家可以看到
凱霞上個禮拜我盤後公布財報
財報不好
所以是直接覺得是不好
不是市場預期太高
是不好
對他就是基本上來講是市場預期太高
但是理論上來講
記憶體的這個財報
應該是要超乎市場預期的
對因為大家對他們的期待很高
所以財報不好
但凱霞今天是上漲
而且在日股大跌的時候
他是上漲
因為他開始回購了
所以我覺得就有點
記憶體感覺上
對利空開始有點慢慢不反應了
所以不管國際股市或台股
我覺得大家可以這樣來看待
南亞科它公布上半年的財報
毛利率都是創下歷史的新高
那今天也是連續兩天漲停辦
所以我覺得它
不管南亞科華邦店望紅
那今天比較可惜就是利基店沒有漲
那利基店我覺得有部分是
因為聯電沒有漲的關係
當然利基店的創辦人
也剛過世啦
這也是科技業的大新聞
對上禮拜傳出來蠻多人覺得很可惜啦
對那目前來看的話
我覺得記憶體整體的狀況
我們不能夠說他馬上轉好
但最少有底部慢慢變高的跡象那大致上來講我覺得記憶體不用擔心的是彩報要擔心的是籌碼所以目前來看你會發現到頭信開始有在回補記憶體了這是一個好消息那另外大戶在上禮拜
其實大部分都在減碼
所以代表說大戶趁著反彈的時候
開始有在做一個
可能自己做一個揮繞結
或是做一個出場的動作
那亞克的關鍵在
他均線多排
季線之上可以去做一個鎖骨
那如果說站穩月線的話
我覺得就可以觀察一下
他有沒有回後買上漲的機會
那目前來看你可以看到
投信慢慢開始有回補記憶體了
這是好消息之一
那融資這段時間也減了
所以就有點類似資減法人買
然後現行慢慢轉向
那當然南亞科是當中大哥
整個型態也是最好的
所以他如果能夠在接下來公布
7月營收利多會漲
回到月線影上的話
對一些比較弱勢的記憶體來講
就有幫助
那華邦電的部分我覺得
他這一波跌比較深
那個南亞科他還在基金影上的時候
他已經來到半年限關卡
那之前其實華邦店比納克強
原因是因為
大概6到7月份的時候
華邦店多了一個被動元件題材
它有細電容的題材
那6月到7月底比較重
是因為華邦店多了一個被動元件的題材
跟著被動元件滑落
都是這樣的啦
因為跟著它上天嘛
當然也跟著它滑落
對 所以之前的票房零藥是被動元件
現在變票房毒藥
那現在你就看變成說
它後面有沒有辦法跟上
第一個那科轉強它會補漲
但轉強的時候
同時你要多看被動元件
如果被動元件也弱的話
那可能拿華邦店它的一個
買氣就會受到一定的影響
但不管怎麼樣
這兩家因為華邦店在禮拜四要
公佈法說會
所以法說會的這個毛利率
獲利的成長跟未來的展望
我覺得會影響到這個禮拜
它反彈的力道
同樣
它只要能夠站穩季線
接日上彎的
那可能就有轉為為安的機會
那接下來看到兩檔所謂的模組場
是 這就更辛苦了對不對
群年已經是到年限了
預創是還沒有
但在半年限跟年限中間
對 那我覺得這兩家公司
但第一個就是會有非常好的財報
是啊 因為群年還沒有公佈
是 那群年你看
第四月份已經字節34.56
所以大家預估第二季大概100塊
那加上半年
所以上半年就160塊
全年大概300多塊
大概跟這個圍影差不多
那股價已經跌到
就算今天反彈到1760
其實本益比還非常低
那目前來看
他是先回到年限關卡
出現了反彈
那我覺得如果說
對群年的投資人來講
這邊你就可以稍微
去等他反彈的情況
因為我覺得有點超跌的跡下
那預創的部分當然比較好
因為預創
我記得上半年賺了6塊多
6.6塊以上
所以如果今年10塊錢
那現在本益比不到8倍
那他不是純模組公司
他是IC設計公司
所以本益比我覺得
反而是變成偏低了
好 因為今天還有一檔叫金豪科
也是漲停辦
都走IC设计
所以我觉得他可能
就大家可以观察一下
他的多题材嘛
有AI眼镜又机器人
所以他股价你就观察一下
月季节能够站上的话
我觉得就可以稍微
比较偏多来看待
好 群联可能很多人心里的痛
因为说实话群联的潘董
已经尽全力在宣传
自家的利多还买股票
潘董也在套牢中啊
所以大家要珍惜群联
因为现在只有潘董
可以相信潘董年底就懂了
好 那我们来看一下
接下来所谓的一个载版族群
那載板當然今天也很整齊
應該說從上禮拜有載板是很整齊在走高的
一反攻載板其實反攻強之外
高震或是說有一些外資
對於他們的目標價都是不離不棄的調高
對 因為他們的夢想是在明年後年的大缺貨
所以上半年其實 EPS 只要角速不錯的成員單
其實外資都還是在調高目標價位
所以我們來看一下
這四檔股票
當然大家會比較關於南電
但南電因為被關
所以我們以景碩來當作當中的代表
那景說你可以看到今天
698塊剛好佔到季線以上
所以形態我覺得
他也算是宅版裡面算是最強的
那一樣
既然是佔到季線以上
但月線下彎
我覺得跟奈爾科超過方法一樣
季線上你可以偏多
縫拉回到季線附近
你可以做一個縫低承接
那什麼時候可以做一個比較機體操作
你就等
他站穩月線
月線上彎之後
我覺得多方形態會更強
那目前來看
因為融資他是逆勢在增加
那投信是有買有賣
所以我覺得這邊還是會呈現震盪
好 那另外一檔星星
你看星星其實形態
它是先破了半年限關卡
它比較弱一點
對 但我覺得它是一個指標
因為它先破了
但你發現到後來利多反應了
開法之後會連續兩根漲銀板
所以目前它反而是先站到月線以上
但我覺得它還在季線之下
所以目前我覺得它還是會來回
整理去洗抽碼
整理上投信是連買
但融資並沒有大幅度的減少
所以我覺得可能它在上去之後
可能大家不要追價
盡量是等拉回之後
重新做個不決的動作
好 所以現在載版的精神領袖
你會看景碩嗎
今天其實一開盤沒有多久
他開非常高就鎖了
是以他為領頭羊的概念嗎
對 如果南電還沒有出來之後
我覺得景碩是優先
那南電出來如果兩檔都一起轉獎的話
我覺得不管是欣欣跟真頂
都有機會加速的補長
是 好 但我們不要忘記載版
現在有四雄啊
對
真頂其實蠻多散物朋友在裡面的
因為他之前價位比較便宜嘛
所以目前真頂怎麼看
我覺得當然真頂
他還是有機會跟他們補漲
但真頂另外一塊是蘋果
對
所以蘋果那個要觀察一下
他在所謂的產品發表
或者之後整個蘋果股價有沒有轉價
就有一些助攻的機會
但目前來看我覺得真頂有的是
可以等他反彈的
好 這邊非常謝謝題材獵人 漢偉哥
好 到底這些利空能不能排除
我們就繼續看下去要看什麼呢
只要每結出一個利多消息
市場願意反應向上
而利空消息市場是淡化處理的時候
那盘差不多在8月就是一个稳定的
再回到产业面上
记忆体陆陆续续要开财报开发说了
肯定都是好消息
所以就要看什么呢
市场对于这样利多
已经跌到有的是到年限的记忆体
愿不愿意重新资金回来青睐他们
这个是观察点
而载版你会发现外资真的不离不弃
除了截出来的数字
确实不断的往上走之后
目标价也一直往上调高
建议现在因为南电被关了
我們先觀察緊碎的動向
它會是現階段載版的領頭一樣
好 廣告回來
雲翔哥要上場了
雲翔哥說為了大家
他賣掉的P又買回來
現在虧損中
可是他會告訴您
CPU跟這個所謂被動元件
今天通通強談
但是他有個SOP來告訴您
誰可以繼續報下去喔
好 我們知道這段時間
很多的高手也会进去抢一个反弹
当然云翔哥没有错过
但他有提到
抢归抢要很厘清自己
短线还是长线
理由会变得不一样
所以今天把SOP给大家
希望不要抢短
最后又变成套牢了
这边当然要先谢谢云翔哥
上礼拜依旧你买不可买
就台股就哗
真的是很惨
现在买了
在台CPU跟被动都是强弹
但是你自己个人觉得
EPS最稳定的其实是厂物
对
大家看一下
以这一波来讲
台主认为说
上次大概也有讲
这感觉像一个三尊头
对
不过现在这样看起来
这个颈线反倒变成一个支撑
因为它强拉之后
基本上你看它等于是
这两天大概有占我们在4千以上
所以我倒觉得说
以目前台股来讲
当然现在最大的一个压力点
就在这个月季线
刚好这个月季线已经纠结在一起
所以这个位置点
我们就姑且把它定在大概四万四
所以我觉得四万四到四万四这个区间
如果横向这样子走
当然是最好
如果在那里就稍微整理过
我倒觉得是对这个所谓的压力解除以后
然后找机会来放量创高
台股可能会重新站上
只有机会
怎么讲着讲着
变成乐观起来了
对 目前来讲是
比较乐观是因为
确实那两天大涨
我觉得说这个代表说
这个买的这个买气还是够强
总体我还是
就是会乖乖买皮啦
好 上礼拜一
跟云翔哥在parkage
建议他要买
结果他就一直说
有反一了先不买
不晓得力道这么强
那现在来讲
接近周三我只能去抓周五
对 所以如果要我买周五可以啦
要等我礼拜三
我现在比较难买
大家不要担心我会
确实在你讲就是说
那天我去买的时候
买的时候
晚上结果这个夜盘有
有下商一千点
所以大概买下去
大概一个小时以后
就净赚三十万
对 所以我先
忍不住跑了一趟
天好可怕
跑了以后
我们的保护伞跑了
跑了以后我就想到这个画面
到时候又被说批没买
所以现在还没有很远
我就大概又把批买回来
所以目前是有批的
现在是亏20万左右
但是我们要认真讲一件事情
其实今天看到涨停
大家心里很矛盾
之前获利没卖
或者台商还没卖又下去
所以我们要怎么判断
能不能续报
其实这总体来讲
就是说大概
接着这个族群
其实都还蛮强的
原则上就是说
如果强反弹来讲
大概原则我们那时候讲说
大概就是最高点下来
然后去抓一个
所谓的黄金切割率
0.382
是一个弱势反弹的满足
不过现在来讲
不要小开的0.382
很恐怖的
0.382如果对国具来讲
肯定要涨个快
快250 300块
200多块
所以我觉得说
目前来讲
我觉得不用看到那么乐观
对
弱势反弹还算乐观
所以现在来讲
反倒跌撑的
先去看月季线的位置点
那我觉得说先去看月线
因为季线可能会在上面
对
那如果在这样的一个空间
还足够的情况下
那当然看
如果筹码洗得比较干净的
那上涨空间比较大
也就是说跌得深
离月线比较远
那基本上业绩又还不错的
那我觉得说抢反弹这一块
还是可以做
就像刚刚浩尔哥也在看
法人增加但是资减
就融资退上
这类型的
这类型都可以
那我们先来看一下
就是备用云圈这一块
因为确实来就是说
今天当然备用云圈
因为春田这个部分
因为它有上修一个资本支出
这资本是上修
当然对整体来讲
认为说这个不只是今年
你看明年基本上还是好的
你会发现
怎么春田跟台湾的这个
这东西很像
所以大家说这次不要再怪国具
因为春田也腰斩了
对 腰斩
那目前看起来就是说
台湾来讲可能是
这些股票来讲
你会发现强度
感觉是还特别强
对 那这里来看到就是说
那时候我有看到就是国具
大概在出头510左右
先吃到一个点停板在460
那今天等于两根掌停板
锁死直接到552
那为什么说
这些基本上当然就是看说
它最主要是第二季的
刚好EPS又出来
那第二季来讲是还不错
大概在4块59
所以有出来的你发现说
其实从营收里面
我们大概就可以看出它
第二季的EPS可以自己推估出来
有的也公布
对 推估出来以后
你会发现
其实跟它的营收成长率
大概很接近
如果没有一些业外的话
基本上大概可以推估
所以如果以这样来讲
我倒认为说
那你可以去估算一些
其他的股票
它有没有这样的利基点
那另外你要注意到一点
就是说
比如说华欣科
它第一季11块69
第二季3块24
这个成长率很高
大概是91
应该有业外的可能性
你看营收
营收只有19%
所以代表說可能有一些業外
所以這時候你會發現說
總體來講
2020年只估到大概10塊錢
對不對
所以大概是沒有真正那麼好
所以它的本益比來講
可能會拉高一點所以明年大概也沒有估那麼高所以以這些來講我還找說相對本益比较低的所以这里面来讲和生糖也是一样就是说跌到400多了它的营收估值来讲
是比较低一点
那它的一个价格也比较高
那另外也要看
就是说起涨点的问题
因为和生糖的起涨点
是从155块开始
所以现在还在快450
500左右
就是说差距来讲还很大
所以像这个来讲
说它的强度可能就
弹起来会没有那么强
那这里面来讲就是说
可能可以注意的像
我上次有讲台庆科
台庆科
对 那台庆科的这个子公司
这个育邦来讲
母子公司
对 那基本上他们来讲
就是它的这个成长性都很高
大概两成到两成五的激增
可是它的EPS来讲
这个育邦大概六月份
单月已经估一块一出来
所以我预估说
可能第二季搞不好有三块二
所以它的EPS成长大概有五成
所以以他的这个本益比来讲
比较低
那明年来讲就是估值更高
加上说这个是一个重点
如果起涨点在一个所谓的
这个没有
现在的位置在他的起涨点左右
那事实上他的这个坛点
可能会比较强
也等于其实他们之前
没有涨那么多
对对
不像人家涨个八倍九倍
没有涨那么多
那我们先来看一下
这个刚好是在上赵豪艾伦说
我们帮云翔哥做专访的那一天
你在那天大坦白
你买了国具
隔天跌停板
但是吃了两根掌停板回来
7月29号
大家有兴趣可以去
达人秀的网站看一下
因为我的想法就是说
其实在这个位置点来讲
我觉得是不要随便接到
我那时候讲说
你抢反弹
不一定是要这个时候抢
可是我那时候看法不是抢反弹
因为我认为说
第二季如果它的EPS很高拉起来
那当年度就已经
这个北一比本来降到24
那如果明年来讲
真的估值可以到三十几块
那北一比可能只有拉到
大概接近15倍
13倍左右那时候讲
所以以这样来讲就是说
当然我的这个底气就够
可以先买一点试试看
所以我不是全买了
所以买了以后基本上
接下来讲大概可以放着
这是看长
那时候专访有这样
那台信客就不一样
台信客因为那时候我们讲说
从这里拉一条线过来
就是说这个是它的一个
所谓的起长点
那已经掉到起长点之下
当然跟其他的这些股票来讲
离其他还有一段距离
对它就是一个
强反弹的一个机会点
所以我那时候讲说
如果它能够越过前低
前一根的低点
然后站上以后
形成第一只脚的情况下
当然你就有机会去强反弹
那强反弹基本上
现在的弱点来讲
当然就是说
你也不用看到0.382
等一下我会讲一下
就是说你至少可以抓
它的个月线左右
那月线离
其实离这个位置点
都还有距离
对所以可以先抓一段
这样的一个反弹
好 等一下会细讲台庆科
谈到哪边可以
那国际也会继续放吗
国际也会放
还会放是不是
好
那华信科来讲
我大概就比较
明天出关
对 我可能就会稍微放掉
对 因为他刚讲的
就是说可能有一些业外
业外
对 所以我担心说
这个业绩有没有那么好
那合胜党基本上就是离
这个所谓的起降点太远了
对 所以他本意来讲偏高
好 今天立院也在吵一件事情
对不对
他又被延长处置了
对对对
关不完
流动性可能会有问题
对 所以我觉得说稍微避开
我自己会稍微避开一下
被处置的就先不要碰了
对不对
这一面来讲
我会去看一支就是预帮
因为我那时候讲说台信科
预帮其实很接近
类似这样的一个状况
它本来就是跟台信科
是一个母子关系
加上说预帮是很纯的
AI的一个被动元件的部分
所以这一面你发现
就是说它的一个大厂的绑的深度很高
包括什么
最近涨得很凶的亚马逊
对NVIDIA
那AMB也是最近很强
所以在这里面来讲
就是说它的公司的强度都很够
第二来讲
它有所谓日本的替代效应
也就是说它的这些晶片
你会发现说比如说
弹电容这个它是有东西可以取代
所以以这样来讲
就是说目前看起来就是说
它的字节6月就1块13
所以估它大概在第二季来讲
达到3块以上
我觉得是可能性非常高
所以这样你雇出来一想
就是说等到业绩出来
它可能会上去
那不如说先做一个布局
那这一样就是说
它的一个起涨点
大概在这个位置点
怎么整个打回来好猛
对 大概在这个位置点
所以以这样来讲就是说
它离0.38非常远
所以你就可以抓说
至少在这个月线
都还有接近270左右
所以这样来讲就是说
它这个基本上还有点距离
加上說它的外資是買
外資增
融資本來就持續降了
所以這個籌碼是相對有利的
所以費動遠距然我會這樣看
那至於產物來講
我會去看就是說
因為那天我們會講雅翔
對
因為本來雅翔我們講說21億的股票
結果它的在手訂單4千多億
4千4百億
所以不知道白老明我幾年了
真的
所以以這樣來講就是說
以它的那個估值
当时我们有去讲说大概六七百
如果跌到六字头六百多
就是真的超低
那你会发现说
第二季大概也可以估得出来
因为营收的估值出来
所以如果估到11块89左右
那整个来讲年大概60块
大概没有问题
所以整个本预比基本上很低
大概就是几倍而已
又回到当年产物十一二三倍
所以这几家产物基本上都还蛮强
只有凡宣可能他的本预比稍微高一点
那这一面来讲
就是我觉得说
以这样的情况下来讲
当然我可能会去找一下
像汉科这样
因为股价很低
132块
股本就大概7亿多
那在手订单也大概100亿
所以以这样来看
就是说
今天如果真的估10块钱
也是本益比93倍
所以大概我倒觉得说
以这个看起来
亚翔是
你会发现
那时候我们讲就是说
大概这个位置点不要去接到
可是那六七百
六字头
对
大概六字头
你看到的时候
对 这里
大概在这位置点
对 有两天的时间
它的业绩来讲
实际上是很够支撑的
对 所以一样就是说
目前来讲一样强
如果强反弹的
大概在800时候
可以稍微看一下
是啊 因为它好像今天
其实有一条五日线
它有压到
它就上不去了
对 所以现在上弹
都要注意这件事
那汉科来讲
基本上我觉得
大概这不用特别多讲
就是说它主要是做
这个气体的配管的一个部分
那加上说它是汉糖的
这个子公司
所以很多订单来讲
它可能配给它
那另外来讲
布局也就是台美日的心中都有
对 所以这个用图解
我也要用这个图解
对 这是新加坡
大家图回去慢慢看
好可爱 全部都有地标
对 再有地标很多
那尤其在先进的
这个2nm以下的这个产物部分
它有聚集攀升
所以它的毛率也很高
然后它的配股率也很高
高配息股
对 高配息大概75%
对 所以这块来讲
它漂亮是说它一直在这里
大概是已经一年多
都是处在一个上升轨道
目前又回到上升轨道下源
对 我是倒觉得说
可以在这个轨道线来回
做一个操作这样子
而且融资使用率很低
对 很低 非常低 只有6%多
那最后一块是CPU
那CPU我觉得说
它大概基本上它是最先跌的
它等于从5月份基本上都已经回头
在5月份左右
那5月份下来以后
基本上你会发现有很多股票
事实上这一波再下来不是低点
像华星光来讲
它是打第二只脚
好 第二只脚
我们讲说
每次下修都找第二只脚
CPU有第二只脚的情况
所以像这样来讲
确实它已经占回
大概月线的部分
所以如果说要抢这样的一个股票
CPO股票
其实像他们基本上
当然技术现行来讲还不错
不过问题是在一个业绩出来
华星光至少有这个年增92%
但波若微就慢慢的了
它的營收是有下來
可是它的單月也不漂亮
數字不夠高
所以目前來講也只能夠說
目前可能短線來講
可能在這個區間我覺得有機會
那另外來講就是說
這個也是只能做一個反彈
反彈一樣以月線
月線來講我覺得是一個
可以看的一個位置點
大概我覺得以CPU來講
大概是可以這樣來看
說實話疊下去的時候
真的叫跌失重值
所以談的話
如果他又有值又會談
可能這個大家會比較放心一點
好 這邊非常謝謝雲翔哥
好 雲翔哥也是有叮嚀啦
現在選擇權的空單不好買
價格落差太大了
他盡力他現在買到禮拜三
禮拜三我們在督促他
買到禮拜五
但無論如何
避險是一個個人在操作上面的策略
大家可以學
而反彈上來
到底哪些該留該報
剛剛講了
基本面最好是比較好的
談起來有底氣嘛
但是遇到重要的軍線過不去
我們可能也要適度的出手把它放掉喔
剛講的SOP學起來
我們在每一波台股下沙的時候
持音保態以及他對未來
雲翔哥看的還是樂觀居多喔
好 廣告回來呢
我們的奇雪王子中哥要上場了
哇 外資空彈已經來到9萬口了
中哥說有可能到10萬口都不稀奇
但是這並不是看彈後世
等一下來教您囉
軍線重要的持續上揚
KD黄金交叉的好股票有哪些
好 那我们今天
其实一开始挺开心的
我们在亚谷里面算是表现最好的
又有100多档涨停板
而且钟哥也观察
各股期的资金流向
已经开始有往风险资产做流动了
但看到外资空单
结出来9万口的时候
我们都吓了一跳
来请教老师的老师
钟哥
9万多口
但是剛剛私底下有問你了
你說還不用太擔心
等一下理由要告訴我們
然後還有上禮拜有教我們
本來是台積電比聯電強
但你發現現在風險
有想要去買聯電了
所以今天教我們這個
十日均往上揚
KD黃金交叉的
可以優先來觀察它
對 那今天下午3點
其實其交所公布那個
籌碼9萬口之後
大家就嚇了一跳
因為創始上新高
那不過因為現在指數相對比較高
已經靠近5萬了
可是无外是前一阵子的事
现在我们都怕死了
当然如果法人的空单很多
他一定有一些目的
要不就是避险
要不就是套利
套利大概就是正价差
才会有比较多空单
但今天其实盘中已经收敛到
几乎是逆价差了
所以这部分你就要先把它排除掉
如果他没有在做套利的话
大概就是避险需求就很高
但只是说我们
像上个礼拜我大涨3000多点
大家也没看过
所以如果空单太多
以前也没看过
那你现在看到其实也不意外
对那我们刚才聊天说
可不可以到十万口
其实今天它就增加了七千口
那你看九万
它如果明天再增加七千
就九万八
所以你到礼拜五前看到十万
也不会太奇怪
真的吗
钟哥你以前有跟我们讲
外资是什么空单很多
是在你家后花园挖洞
以前说是在挖墙壁
那因为现在已经没有墙壁了
现在就是无国际的状态
所以大家还是要留意一下
那我觉得外资它有点过度看空
那怎么说
我们从三个风险指标来看
第一个就是美元
美元当然因为跟这个美日联合去拉日元有关
所以美元指数在这个这几天
其实相对都落势
但我们从过去的经验来看
如果美元比较弱的话
照理说它就会把钱留到雅谷
因为它不可能放在美国
而且它的月线现在看起来有点下弯
我们不会像说过去
如果这样子一路往上走的时候
美元强他们就会去卖亚古
他会把钱留回美国
所以从美元指数的角度看起来
现在的股市是稍微短线偏多来看这是OK那再来是油油价的话我想这边晃来晃去那刚才那个汉伟哥大家有讲过一些的概念就是伊朗跟美国的战争
其实已经不会影响到股市了
我觉得短线就是杂音
对那基本面还是要去看一下
回到这个股市的状态
那再来是VIX
这我觉得这个是对多方最有利的
那前高在这边是6月8号
对6月8号
那再来这一波的高
其实它没有过它
这个概念我们其实有讲过了
但我们会发现
例如说你看费半或是看台股都一样
已经比这个6.18还要再更低
就是你只要超过它了
其实都是超跌的
那今天也是一样
你看这个夜盘现在在下跌
那VIX应该没有动
对
日元汇率的急升
我们曾经历经过一次
也是全球去杠杆
这一次有没有这样的疑虑在呢
因为日股今天也是翻黑
我觉得利空大家听到第一次会最害怕
那这个叫carry trade
carry trade其实以前听过了
你现在在听到就没那么害怕
除非有新的利空
是你没听过的
那可能大盘就会有比较大的震动
就像南韩这样去杠杆
以前没听过嘛
那现在来了对不对
那如果下礼拜你又听到南韩在去杠杆
我们也听过啦
所以也不会再跌这么多
好 希望是如此
最惨重的跌是已经过去
对 那这个礼拜我觉得要注意
因为有很多的这个大企业的财报
像spex S
或是像这个AMD
那我觉得最后是礼拜五
礼拜五是飞农
那飞农的话
上上一次就是6月8号
大盘不是重挫吗
就我们刚才说那BIS冲起来那一次
就是因为数据太好
对
对 暴裂的飞农
怕升息
那这一次一样
预估大概是9.1万人左右
大概9万人
那前值是5.7
所以这一次也很紧张
为什么
因为你不能太好也不能太坏
对 这就是飞农
让我觉得最头痛的
太坏大家觉得市场经济转坏
也不行
而且那个华许
它未来会比较少公布利率点证图
它也没有前瞻指引
所以华小街可能会更重视一下经济数据
所以这个这一次就还蛮重要
你会看到公布的时候
那个纳斯达克 S&P就上下乱扫
上下乱扫
但是可能过一个小时之后
就会回复到正常的状况
那你就要留意一下
少于5万人或是大于15万人
就是要警戒
好不要有极端值
对太好太坏其实都不太好
那再来我们来看这个台湾
台湾我们刚才说
大家很紧张9万口
那散户呢
散户今天稍微有点做多
那这波散户比较特别
上个礼拜五这个最大的涨点之前
它是多单的
也就是常常有人会说
会不会散户也会偶尔赚到钱
那我们知道坏掉的时钟
一天会准两次
所以我觉得它这次是做对
那而且很厉害
就是你看这个大盘往下修正
其实融资减的跟大盘差不多
但是散户它完全没有什么动
你看这个掉下来
就是围台没动
对 它的多单还蛮多的
就是期货的投资人跟融资的投资人
我觉得是不太一样
有可能是变成两种人
对 我觉得长期它可能还是错的
这个要留意一下
外资这边9万口
这已经创始上新高
当然如果它现货还没有什么买超
但期货一直增加的话
我想它的避险需求越来越大
对下半周的压力
我觉得会比较重一些
好我们还是对
虽然是现在越来越习惯
没看过的东西
还是要留意啦
是对
好那这是那个筹码
再来我们来看到
我们观察到一些现象
我们上个礼拜有讲
那个多空配对交易
对
那这个有点难啦
我想在市场上
配对的人应该不多
可是还蛮多人问的
然后还蛮多人问说
这到底是什么软体啊
这个红线到底怎么算的啊
这个平台叫做MultiChart
就是Multi
多元的图表
那个英文字Multi-Chall
那很多的期货商跟券商其实都有
那刚好我也会用
所以我就大家利用了一下
那我们看下方这个指标呢
我们有讲过
假设这个台积电是A好了
那连电是B好了
那这个指标其实就是
我们把A-B去除以A加B
那这样听起来会很复杂吗
我觉得好像还好
就是当你这个变成红色
代表A比较强
那你看A比较强的时候
是不是台积电相对就强
要不就是强
要不就是比较抗跌
所以你看前一波
从这边开始转红的时候
这个是不是都转红
转红台积电
我们说台积电强嘛
那连电是不是要弱
那我们这边呢
这个做多台积电这一次呢
我们会大概亏损4400块
然后呢你放空台积电
我们要假设四口对四口
连电吗
连电
我们这边会赚18万
所以你看大盘不管怎么跌
它是不是修正
我们也没有差
因为你是多空配对
那我们说最近翻成绿色了
怎么了
绿色代表什么
这个台积电落于连电
也就是以前大家会把钱塞在台积电
因为大盘去杠杆好紧张
台积电最稳了
所以塞进去
那你看现在今天是不是很多股票
持续反弹第二天
代表钱都跑出来了
所以我们就要提防什么
提防这个指标再度变成红色的
假设再转红
钱又全部塞为台积电
就是风险因素又提高了
对那你像被动啊
记忆体或者像这种细晶元等等
又会再跌
所以是要留意一下最近的盘面的变化
大家广告计订阅一下这个平台
来看一下
这钱躲到台积电
其实就是中小型股会很弱
真的就是这样
好那这样我们来看
假设我们要选股的话
我们简单的用一些方式
例如说这个股票基金
持有档次比较多的
然后10天均线上扬
融资增加市场上半前100年
再次的说明
这是比较聪明的积极的融资
对我常常在选这个时候
会被那个
比如说我们在演讲
然后台下就会
观众就会质疑说
融资不是都会赔钱吗
而且他们都会把筹码用得很乱
你为什么要选它
而且像刚刚前两位来宾有讲
是要那种法人增加融资
会比较好啊
对不对
对那我这样讲好像
有点冲突
但是我们发现
我们在量化选择的时候
这样好像绩效变得很好
对所以我们还是会把它挑进来
因为大户也会用融资
对然后在大盘比较震荡的时候
会加上这个条件
就是本益比比较太高的
所以它小于40倍
40倍还蛮高的
我才把它挑进来
那有些五六十倍以上的话
我就不会去考虑买它
所以这样选的话
我现在持股大概有
一二三大概有九到十档左右
好稳定的持股
而且啊
因为这个条件
那这十档目前持有的部位
而且还是赚钱
当然主要的获利是在伪创
我们来看伪创
那今天8月3号
我们可以买进三档
伟创期 群益正期跟第一金期
这三档的期货
那我们买都是在9点
就是现货开盘期
我们就会进场
那你看伟创
这是伟创的江波图
那现货9点一开之后
它掉下来
那我们买在173
就大概是在平盘下面的位置
那刚好呢
好久不久它就这样往上拉了
所以它这一档的获利
目前还蛮多的
那其他的呢
你看除了这个
神达 中华电 台湾大之后
其他全部都是金融类股
而且这些都是你讲的
五天短打对吗
对 我们都只报五天
然后停损停力
把它设定好之后
那伟创我们按照这样选
其实上个礼拜应该也有
就有选出来过
到现在涨9.4%
9.4%其实也不多
因为一根涨停其实就10%
但是用个股其实有杠杆的
对 好 那我们看
为什么挑它
我们说这个十日均线上扬
那它其实已经创一个
近期这个平台的高
那好像要去挑战
这个前高的感觉
那我们看一下
这融资
融资其实它在市场上面
前十天
它是前100名的股票
所以才会被挑出来
那这是一个选股的方式
那另外我们再介绍一种
我们之前常用的
就是量增股期
量增股期的话
一样我们去怎么看呢
有三个条件
第一个就是KD
它刚好要黄金交叉
我们说如果K大于低的话
很简单很容易发生
但是如果你要黄金交叉
它就只会有在那一刻
它不可能长期会有很多档
所以今天的档次并没有很多
大概四到六档
KD黄金交叉
那十天均线它是上扬的
古旗的量能超过500口
对三个条件符合
那第一档就鸿海
鸿海
不过它也偏有点小防御吧
对不对
它也是防御型的
你看这个从前一波7月17
这个史上最大跌点开始到现在
它其实没有太大的修正
今天连续两天一样都是红棒
KD今天黄金交叉
均线还在上扬
所以可以留意一下
它的后续的一些表现
当然它的题材还是很多
只要AI没有泡沫的话
它一定会吃到相关的红利
就是妥妥的组装代工
第一档红海
再来就是景硕
均线还在上扬
连续两天都是一字线
一字线的话就是代表很强势
那明天也许还有这个机会
那因为这连续两天的跳空
那KD黄金交叉了
所以这个可以留意
这个就是后续
还有表现的这个状态
因为你也单名中
我们也只能叫你中哥
对不对
总不能叫中帝
但是他的
他的今天是锁涨停
这样还是可以锁定他吗
就是已经连续锁涨停了
因为我们这样的选股
他是没有排除涨停跟跌停
所以如果挑出来的话
还是可以观察
好
那只是说现在夜盘
表现比较差
它如果我们开低之后
你再考虑也许可以低接
对对对
这是一个交易的方式
那再来这个是金豪科
金豪科一样是记忆体的这个状况
一样连续谈两天了
那谈到这个月线
那这算强
有的股票其实都还离月线有一段的距离
就像被动元件那个就稍微比较辛苦
那你看KD一样黄金交叉第一天
这个也可以留意
那第四档会比较特别就是2603的长龙
它是最近真正的避风港
走到货柜航运上
你看从180
7月初一来
把它直接慢慢的涨上了
风浪虽大
但货柜航运挺稳的
对那这跟这个金融股很多
其实还是都很像
就是防御型的这个股票
那样均线正在上升
而且它是站在这个均线的上方
KD一样今天第一天黄金交叉
对那它的这个基本面
其实都很好
因为它的殖利率也很高
假设你是喜欢这个
高股息的标的的话
你也常常都会选到它
所以这是另外一种
交易的逻辑
那他们到底要报到什么时间呢
还是就像中哥教我们的报五天呢
我们的报五天是指我们的量化选股
那如果我是用KD选的话
其实就有很多元的出场方式
假设你可以
例如说跌破前三天的低影就出
或是均线下弯
或是这个跌破均线下
其实都可以
好或者是遇到像最近有很多是均线反压
可能到了一个压力点等等的
大家还是要散射一个出场点
把获利保住
这边非常谢谢钟哥
钟哥每次来
其实都教学蛮多东西的
上个礼拜教我们这个配对交易
我们可以把获利锁起来之外
如果做对方向的话
我们还可以额外获利躲开
这一次崩盘的一个状态
不过现在可以看得出来
从台积电跟联电的配对
市场有把钱往风险资产来做挪移
但是我们选股还是要小心
因为最近的波动相当的大
这个KD要往上交叉
其实选出来的股票并不多
也相对是比较稳健的
还有大家要擅设自己
这一波反弹的停利点
但中哥也说外资空单九万口
我们把这个事情放在心里面
不过在盘面上
因为现在有点叫见怪不怪
我们也不要过度恐惧
这些事情我们都要到台股的盘面上
形成一个平衡点
今天非常谢谢三位来宾来到现场
台股今天算是雅谷里面最强的
不过说实话
我们还是要继续观察
利多的消息
接下来的财报半年报啊等等的法术会
能不能继续让利多的效应往上跑
而利空慢慢的沉淀哦
遇到反弹
我们自己要善事一个停利的出场点哦
那也希望今天理财答案秀
对您投资有帮助哦
明天再会了
拜拜